yeah welcome to this video and let's see
we didn't use oh we have 92 line
Reshevsky variation I have this rook e8
move prepared against that 93 I think I
played this 65 against that watch now
yeah more than one possible way to play
maybe 96
is he threatening to take me to take on
c6 doubling the pawns but it's really
not a lot an issue so we have a very
close position it's not easy to make
substantial progress in this should I
take on before I think I think at one
point I should know g6 looks quite solid
hmm yeah Peter ship Bishop g5 is not not
a good move okay here II routed to the
suburban maybe if I go here he's
probably taking b7 okay it's protected
1972 a5 smart idea yeah I can simplify
but helpful I have a bit less space so
some locations on our welcome the good
thing about positions with less space I
quite often is that you don't have any
substantial weaknesses you've got
everything neatly placed on to ranks and
you didn't expose yourself to much
themselves of week Square supports and
here for example d4 can be and can be a
target that's easy for what not to to
not exchange
and this is one possible way to not
exchange but c6 looks like a move that
black young likes to play anyway
question is what no defy him it's for me
not too bad Knight g5 is probably
retreating now but this is simple and
good I think
now here trading
yeah if nicely position bishops yep yeah
I think that this should be about equal
yeah probably its equal it's very hard
to claim in an edge for for one side
yeah interesting I have an interesting
option now I can take on III and play
Queen b6 okay let's try that that's an
interesting problem exchange sec
good very active bishops rugby through
this Bishop c2 I didn't see that before
I just thought okay it's interesting
didn't calculate there
check
the question is whatever dream button in
or there's no question Brooke curve see
one
Roxie one was strong yeah it is strong
don't really see what he's doing now
we're taking the Queen and wherever is
it going
Queen a4 I can take and play Bishop
before threatening Queen g'wan mate this
is check quite a substantial threat
let's in fact so substantial that's very
sign
yeah that you have no move it is just a
maid and this was a very quick knock out
all of a sudden but rookie three I think
it's a good move they have a comp also
wants to do that it was a bit lucky
I must admit because after Queen b6 I
didn't really see Luke a3 I thought I
just wind the pawn thought okay we treat
somewhere that take III I've got a pawn
but it was lucky that after that I have
Bishop b2 word you know the rook doesn't
have any square as it's all it's all
covered here could see - yeah this is
nice
call it quite a nice win to go back to
the game yeah here yes it's just it's
just over
he needs to play rook takes b2 to keep
the game going for bit longer but it's
also pretty pretty hopeless something
like this alright thanks for watching